drea first of all I'm told that you had
a confession that you wanted to make
here on the air and this is true this is
real right away the second right away
let's get this out of the way let's
what's the most nervous person here okay
I was supposed to come on your show back
when you were on what was it an NBC I
can't remember what your network it was
but yeah all kind of hazy but anyway
yeah I was on NBC and I was doing the
late night show and you were doing The
Sopranos and you were booked to come on
the show yes I was and I called in sick
the day of and told you that my dog was
dying because I was so incredibly
nervous to come on show you were nervous
well hey you're my favorite I've been
obsessed with you forever so I was
petrified to come on the show I get
nervous for talk show things everything
I have so many liners on my armpits
right now it's right so do I remembered
you called us and you said that your dog
was dying yes I've made up a big lie
that my dog was dying and you sent me
flowers yeah and it wasn't true so
nervous yeah well you're here now and
we're thrilled we're thrilled that
you're here and then all your animals
are well someone to kill your dog
page 24 tummy boob go take care of the
dog
you